it's also a woman fashion of dues if
you're a woman you would have the
tightest [ __ ] look at that mouth oh
look at this I have a tiny mouth and no
lips part of the reason why I grew the
beard was so people would know where the
noises first time I kissed a girl gamer
paper what if we took my mouth yeah put
on your face or if I had your eyes yeah
like the tiny eyes and a tiny mouth oh
that would be unforgivable
Lord Jesus if I had a tiny mouth - yeah
and no live like you someone Photoshop
the hell out of run your dad Michael
Jackson's nose my eyes your mouth my
drink
well we'll be millionaires yeah we were
people lined up like a dollar - fair
yeah no you I remember one time I didn't
know that Bubba Gump shrimp was a
franchise wait you I I thought the same
thing okay wait so here's what I thought
coming from the Philippines I thought
that the movie made the Bubba Gump me
too that's not the case no the case is
this okay Bubba Gump right was it what
is the it's it's been there since the
20s 19 points got me right now no Bubba
Gump has been around since maybe even
before that but in that it was like the
one the first shrimping
you mean okay company yeah and that and
that the movie definitely stole not
Staubach a star and they changed it a
bit that's what they did with the Bubba
comp we did it with Nike they did with
Nike they do with a lot of historical
things where he was John they put
Forrest Gump with John Nixon not John
Nixon Richard Nixon stuff like that but
you inspired me like I loved yours I
lied just now the whole thing just now
yeah yeah he totally like I'm looking at
okay so I liked your fashion like yeah I
didn't shop at thrift stores or
Goodwill's until I met you that's the
cool that's the cool thing I want to be
cool like Bobby you know just about
wristbands dude that's right you know
who else Tony the wristbands for him Ari
Shaffir uh-huh I had a lot choroid pants
from a thrift store yeah got the
t-shirts like that the ones had crazy
logos and stuff that you don't think
about yeah and then I saw one that said
Bubba Gump on it I go oh I like that one
I like the movie
I'll wear that to the Comedy Store
there's lots people talk about the BLA
and you're like really
but you said take this shirt off don't
wear that shirt man you said don't wear
that shirt I'm trying to help you John
don't wear the shirt and then what'd you
say I said really and I thought like
that's funny Appalachian and but I
didn't think of it then but did it it's
remember it stayed with me for the rest
of my life because if you had worn that
shirt right it doesn't wear these shirts
yeah is because they are a one of a kind
it's old it's not that's what I'm
praying it's not current franchise it's
making billions of dollars yeah yeah you
were serious about it right when most
people wear fun shirts like that I have
a Rambo 3 shirt it's ironic historian
yeah right your eyes either all it was
little yeah he's right yes right what
Sebastian I told you about that's your
story right
Sebastian comes to the comedy store
wearing these Italian shoes uh-huh you
know this is right when he started
making money but he had these Italian
shoes where it was like leather really
nice shiny but it was shaped in the
front like a ninja shoe what a tote
would oh yeah so the toe is helped
settle on the resume for the rest of the
pool so he comes in with this thing that
number one I've never seen before
or after all right it doesn't exist
right right
and number three I don't get he was
costume thousand a lard from Italy oh
boy so I go he got as a gift though and
I go I think you 200 bucks for those
right now we give it to me he didn't he
didn't he needed the money I think sure
you better buy these with 200 bucks I
got ya I got ya sagres alright but what
am I gonna wear
I'd slippers like a popsicle I gave him
the flip-flop and I took those shoes and
in front of him I throw him the dumpster
my god and whatever he react to that we
laughed for a probably three hours
spring but I I do that yes I don't say
that I believe you yeah yeah no yeah I
think it's two things you're doing
you're being funny but you're also like
honestly John that's well I think you're
a cool person ed but that's not a cool
shirt and you were trying to be better
yeah in a weird way dude you know it's
also a Dickey thing but it's okay I have
that too it's fine yeah yeah we checked
off together oh you can say things like
that it's like Nam it's like serving in
Nam together is that kind of like we
went through the mud in the blue eye
[Music]
forever